[Music]
now your your co-star just pulled off a
very private wedding something that you
know a little thing or two about got
ready I just found out about that I
didn't know really what happen I know um
yeah Congrats tan
good friend making a problem Justin
Theroux and dave franco lend their
voices to the upcoming lego ninjago
movie but it's not the only thing they
have in common both actors pulled off
secret weddings Justin and Jennifer
Aniston in 2015 and Dave and Alison Brie
earlier this month your experience
making it private I mean how much more
special was that it's a so much special
more special when it's just yours and
plus his friends and family and it's
lovely and we want it to be a peaceful
environment
sir oh please bad guy Gor Madan in the
lego ninjago movie you ruined my life
that's not true I haven't even been a
part of your life how could I ruin it
wasn't even there
I get to have the fun of the bad guy you
completely narcissistic and skins angry
and wanting to take a written jag open
everything but it's not sorrows only
role that has Hollywood buzzing got
asked you also want to buzz about star
wars episode 8 and your name being
involved thing about this this is fair
like you don't know anything about this
I know something about it but I don't
know much well I haven't seen the movie
yet we'll see
[Music]
you